he is eric decosta eric welcome back how
are you
i'm doing great mike how are you doing
i'm doing great and you know every once
in a while when i do one of these
interviews i actually take a second or
two to do some research and
i realized that you have been with the
ravens
for
25
years
that is unheard of
in this business how in the world have
you stayed
in one place
in the nfl where everybody's always
moving around have you done it for 25
years
i try to be nice to people mike
[Laughter]
i've been a great run i've been
fortunate to have a lot of great people
working here coaches and scouts
tremendous ownership over the years and
it's just a great place to work so i've
never wanted to leave plus my wife is
from here so she's never let me leave
but it's nearly half your life and it's
the first job you took in the nfl what
was your mindset when you started
because you're walking into a business
where
everybody's always moving around after a
year or two there's an opportunity
somewhere else or you're asked to leave
or whatever the case may be
when you started did you have any
inkling that you were going to put down
roots inside if i'd be and and one of
the great pieces of advice that somebody
gave me a long time ago was
understand what everybody else is doing
what their jobs are in the organization
and so early on i tried to
understand what the equipment managers
did and the trainers and the pr people
and the community relations people
and uh and i think that's been a secret
of my success
you know one of the realities now that
we're the old guys and we can impart
advice to others is
that willingness and that drive and that
determination early on
to pay your dues to bust your ass
to prove yourself that way no one's
going to install you
in a big job when you walk through the
door you got to earn it and one way that
you prove the earn it in addition to
being nice to everybody and not pissing
anyone off and not having people there
who want to get rid of you is you work
hard and people notice hard work you
don't have to go tell everybody hey look
how hard i'm working they notice if
you're working hard
yeah i think that's true mike and then i
also think that a little success breeds
continuity and one of the things that i
think people would admire about the
ravens is the fact that we've been able
to sustain continuity for so long with
only two general managers and three head
coaches
that makes a big difference in
organizations at any level and i think
that's something that's quietly made us
a very good organization well and i
think you're right you know it's easy
for other teams to want to emulate
franchises like the ravens and the
steelers and have continuity and
stability it's easy to do it if you
continue
to be successful because then you never
hit that stretch where maybe ownership
is bowing to pressure from fans to make
a change and it is amazing that when you
consider it two of the models of
consistency
in the entire league are in the same
division battling with each other every
year yet both have been good enough that
you can enjoy that consistency and
stability for a period of decades
that's true and and i think you have to
have a lot of admiration for uh the
rooney family and the bashadis steve as
well for being patient
and understanding the challenges unique
challenges in this business
in that uh you know sometimes it takes
time to build something that will
long-term sustain
all right now that the draft is over
we've had a week since round one what
grade would you give the baltimore
ravens 2021 draft
i'd probably give him a c plus b
you know b i mean nobody really knows
mike um you know some of the best drafts
i thought we ever had
ended up
probably being some of the worst drafts
we ever had and then on the flip side of
that you know you'll have a draft that
uh
looks like you know average on paper but
then as you go back and look at it four
or five years down the road um you just
can't believe how lucky you got so
there's so many factors that go into a
draft one of the biggest things is just
players staying healthy and getting a
chance to play
you know durability is a critical thing
for players and uh guys that stay
healthy and play usually end up playing
pretty well and contributing and then
sometimes you take a guy as you know
you've seen it a million times a guy
gets picked pretty high and the first
thing that happens to me training camp
is he gets hurt and that doesn't bode
well for your draft class
isn't it amazing though that with all
the money and the resources and the
analytics and the formulas and the
different technologies and devices
available
we're still no closer to cracking the
code
on
finding the guys in round one that
everyone believes and
well everyone does believe going in that
they're going to be great but they
actually become great it it still seems
like it's the most elusive quality in
the nfl connecting
any type of certainty between the pick
you make and whether or not that guy's
gonna end up being a good player
yeah that's a great point and i think
that's it's really based on three
different things it's based on the
evaluation of the player as a player
it's based on the the player as a person
and also as i alluded to earlier the
injury component and so those three
things
usually conspire to uh you know help
your determination of the player and and
so a lot of times you know we can watch
the tape and we can say oh this guy's a
really talented player but maybe we
don't understand his drivers or
motivations uh as a person and sometimes
again we might say this guy's wired the
right way he's a very good player but he
can't stay healthy on the flip side of
that sometimes you get a guy that on
tape looks like an average player
and has the mentality uh the uh
personality to really succeed and those
guys usually over achieve those are the
guys that go in the fourth fifth round
people say how did that guy fall so so
far you know two or three years later
well it's usually because there's
something special about him and his
personality that enables him to over
achieve and become a better player than
most people think i'm a firm believer
too in the reality that for some guys
the indignity of going later than what
they thought they would go lights a fire
that might not otherwise have been there
if they'd gone in the first round if
they hadn't been the 199th pick in the
draft or just like with receivers i
think if you fought around two
you got a potential michael thomas
motivation where that never is going to
go out that fire isn't going to be
extinguished is that real do you see
that
yeah we see that even in the in the
phone calls that we made to these guys
when we draft them so there's really
three different types of phone calls
there's the guy you call who expected to
be picked
there's the guy that you call
who just he's so overcome with emotion
because he can't believe he's gotten
this far and he's he can't he's just so
happy to even be picked and then there's
the third class the player that's kind
of pissed off quite honestly that they
didn't go higher than they should have
been and we had a few of those this year
too they're a little bit surly they're a
little bit sullen they're a little bit
short with you on the phone they're very
happy and relieved but they're not over
the top ecstatic or emotional because
they want it to be picked higher than
they were picked
i've never thought of that aspect of
it's almost to shoot the messenger type
thing you're the team that is ending the
slide but they're mad because you're the
first one they get a chance to vent
toward and uh you know that i i do think
that's a real dynamic we get motivated
by all sorts of things as human beings
and that perception or reality of
disrespect i think has fueled a lot of
guys to be better than maybe they would
have been you guys have been excellent
when it comes to
compensatory draft picks i think the
ravens understand and implement the
formula as well if not better than any
team in the nfl i'm curious about one
thing though because this year and i'll
just use two guys as an example
you sign sammy watkins during the window
where that counts
toward the compensatory draft pick
formula but
you waited on alejandro villanueva what
factors do you look at to decide which
guy you'll make a move on knowing that
it's going to affect the compensatory
draft pick formula and which guys will
you wait for
well i don't want to get too much into
this um but i do i want you to i know
but i think what we what we try to do
number one is we look at the surplus or
we look at the deficit so how many
players have we signed
how many players have we lost
that gives us an indication of how many
comp picks we're going to get
then we look at the type of comp pick
that we would expect to get based on the
contracts of the players who left so
you know we can tell by the range of the
average of the salary what that's going
to be what bucket that's going to fall
into
um
and then we we sort of talk about what
we want to preserve and what picks would
be worth preserving versus what picks
are we comfortable giving away to get a
good player once you get to that point
then you have to look at
preserving those picks and how much
money you could spend in a contract and
still preserve those picks and that's
there's a slippery slope there's a fine
line there
as to what that contract average has to
be and we spend a lot of time talking
about that because if you end up
spending a certain amount on a on a
contract then you're going to lose the
comp pick
if you understand how the cop picks work
and you spend under a specific amount
then you're going to preserve the the
con the complex that you want to
preserve at the expense of the comp
picks that you really don't care about
throwing away so
you know i think this is something over
time
that we've really done a really good job
with
in the early days of the comp pix we
were very involved but we didn't
necessarily understand all the nuances
and i think over time
pat moriarty nick mario ozzie newsom
they've done a really really good job of
understanding this complex thing and
helping to help us make decisions that
work for us
and that that commitment to maximizing
the compensatory draft picks and not
undermining the picture may have
available you know to put it in terms
that the average fan can understand i
sense that the ravens
particularly appreciate the fact that
these draft picks ultimately are lottery
tickets and the more that you have to
scratch off
the greater the chance you're going to
get a winner
yeah i think many years ago there was a
great article that was written um it was
an economics article and uh
the authors their basic premise was that
the draft in and of itself is just a
luck driven process
uh and i and i believe that you know uh
these were two guys at the university of
chicago and they there's about 50 pages
and i couldn't understand a lot of the
math but i understood the basic points
which was the more picks you have the
better chance you're going to have of
building a strong team so we've always
been one of those teams we've tried to
collect as many draft picks as possible
understanding that the draft picks a
currency that we can use
and the thing is yes we have the draft
picks to pick but now we also have the
draft picks to move up to move down to
trade future year picks they create an
amount of flexibility that we think is
beneficial to the club
and that value of waiting for the window
to close on the compensatory draft pick
formula that that hinges on the players
still being available and the guy that
you signed this year alejandro
villanueva
why do you think he was available for as
long as he was i thought he'd have been
gone by the time the compensatory draft
pick window closed
yeah good question you know uh over the
years we've signed some guys uh after
the window daryl smith was another guy a
few years ago i mean more than a few
years ago now but he was a linebacker
for us who was a very good player for us
uh just no way of knowing uh sometimes
it can be the fact that maybe the agent
has overshot the market possibly in
talking to teams it could be
something like an injury concern i mean
there's a million different variables
that go into that we brought alan a few
weeks ago spent some time with him we
were very impressed
and we started negotiations this week
after we were not able to get a tackle
in the draft
and um you know i think he liked our
situation we liked his situation we've
played against him twice a year and we
felt he was a good fit for the football
team you had to breathe a sigh of relief
when the juwan james injury happened in
denver
the same day that you announced the
villanova signing because with mike
munchek there the former offensive line
coach in pittsburgh i assume the broncos
would have quickly come to the table
you know this in this business mike
sometimes you get lucky sometimes you
get unlucky uh you know i think we had a
good plan
i do think that
the fact that we were able to bring an
allen allen a few weeks ago and spent
some time with him helped in that regard
uh i think that you know it there's
other factors as well i you know his
wife's got some family here i believe
um
you know i think al likes the fact that
we're a military town with annapolis
down the road navy
um it just was a good fit for him and i
think a good fit for us and we're
excited about it
i don't know if you saw this before the
draft but bucky brooks of nfl media
floated a theory an idea a possibility
that for your quarterback situation
maybe one way to go would be to draft a
young guy and as bucky brooks termed it
let lamar jackson graduate is that
something that landed on your radar
screen and did you have any thoughts
about that theory
no not really we've got some good young
quarterbacks that we like in trace
mcsorley and huntley
and uh obviously lamar we look at him as
really a tremendous person and a great
talent and just a guy that we know we
can build this team around so
we're very excited about the future
it's just really great to have a bunch
of guys working together on offense that
really care and we're a different
offense we like that
we see an opportunity for us in terms of
building our offense out and looking at
different players that maybe other teams
don't like quite as much
we have a good defense a good special
team is a great coaching staff and we
think we're in prime position to succeed
you've made it clear that you have every
intent of signing lamar jackson to a
long-term contract and keeping him on
the team the fact that he is up for a
deal at the same time
other quarterbacks from his draft class
are up for new deals does that
complicate the process do you sense
reluctance that well i want to see what
the other guy gets before i try to get
mine because then that's my benchmark is
any of that going on with these three
quarterbacks from the class of 2018 who
are all in line for new contracts
you know i don't know yeah that's a good
question i mean we've been in situations
like this we're in a situation like this
with ronnie stanley and tonsille and
bactiari and guys like that and then we
were in a similar situation with marlon
humphrey and tridavius white and jaylen
ramsey and so what i always think to
myself is we're going to do the best
deal we can for the ravens i mean we
certainly will consider other deals and
other ways of doing deals and different
things but we're going to negotiate and
do the best deal we can for the club
that also makes sense for the player
how does it complicate things for you
that lamar jackson doesn't have a
traditional agent
uh you know it
i don't know that it complicates things
if it makes things easier i'm not really
sure you know i think that the biggest
thing is communication
for me and lamar to communicate you know
we've already done a deal with lamar we
did a rookie deal with lamar now
obviously wasn't the same but we did we
understand some of the complications
because we did that prior deal this is a
much different deal with a much
different structure and things like that
but
i think that sometimes having the
general manager and the salary cap
people talking directly to the player
really does improve communication i mean
what we see sometimes is that
we will have conversations with an agent
and in some cases the player is not even
aware of that
um so that won't be the case here i
think the transparency will probably be
pretty significant that would be pretty
good
and you know i've uh i hope
that
you know if lamar has questions he can
get the answers i know he has people
that he trusts and respects that can
help him and advise him
uh because this is a big deal and and we
want to do it right we want to do
something he feels really good about and
we want to do something that we feel
really good about as well
it would seem to me that sometimes
negotiations can become challenging they
can become difficult sometimes difficult
things need to be said it's got to be
harder
if you have to say something difficult
directly to the player instead of to a
third party
that you know for example if there's a
concern about the player's skill set a
concern about this a concern about that
that would knock down the value
it's just part of the negotiation ritual
it's got to be harder to say that
directly to the player
and i think that's true mike uh one
thing i've learned as a gm in my short
time as a gm is that you'd have to have
a lot of difficult conversations with
players every single day it could be
about discipline it could be about
social media a family issue an on the
field issue an off the field issue
and as a gm you've got to be able to do
that and if you can't do that you
probably should be doing something else
i have a theory that you know we went
from a time where every quarterback
that played well well enough to get a
second contract it was almost like the
old game where you put your hand on the
baseball bat each guy goes one higher
until you get to the top i feel like
that's changing now that there's going
to be tiers for quarterbacks you're
going to have a handful
in the 45 million or more range and then
you're going to have other tiers for
other levels of quarterback do you see
it evolving that way because i just
don't think it's sustainable
for
every quarterback who comes along he's
good enough that you want to keep him
yeah the benchmark becomes getting more
than whoever the highest paid
quarterback is
well i think that should apply in in all
aspects of football
gm's coaches players all players really
i mean the best guys should be paid the
most and then you know you can't just
expect to be paid more because you're
the latest guy
and um again that's something that as a
as a gm
that you you have to try to you know
that point you have to try to make with
your players and and the club is also
obligated to do the best thing for the
club based on the other good players on
the team under the parameters of the
salary cap so
we we try to build something that we can
sustain for a very long time other teams
have been successful doing that some
teams haven't but we want to try to keep
all of our good players as best as we
can and sometimes
that means that you can't give all the
money to certain players and you know um
you have to make tough choices in
lamar's case we're talking about an mvp
we're talking about a quarterback uh
we're talking about one of our very very
best players
um
we know we've been fortunate to have a
quarterback on a rookie deal
that's just part of it and that's going
to change at some point and when it does
we'll have to make some tough decisions
with the roster uh but i would argue
that's a good problem to have
you had a great quote from one of your
pre-draft press conferences about the
receiver position and
you said that the receivers on the team
are insulted by the perception that the
receivers aren't very good and you're
personally insulted by it and it was
great we played it on one of our shows
we reacted to it and then you drafted
two receivers one in round one and
running one in round four how do we
reconcile what you said about the
receivers before the draft with the fact
that you drafted two more
well it was before the draft
like yeah that tries to read too much
you know what people say or the draft
you know they're acting foolish and you
know we're trying to win everything we
do is based on does this help our club
win
does this put us in the best position to
win so yeah as you know mike you write
about it all the time
there's a lot of foolishness being said
before the draft anonymous scouts and
things like that we don't really play
that game but for me to stand up there
and talk about how we're going to build
the team
you know before the draft is probably
not the smartest thing in the world so
uh what i said really in my intentions
was that
i believe our receivers do
want to be the best they do care about
that and we believe in those guys
um we're still gonna build the very best
team we can build at any point now
before the season during training camp
after the season whatever that might be
there's gamesmanship involved and
there's a strategy involved and for me
to go up there and say we're going to
draft a receiver in the first round that
would be foolish and everybody should
understand that um on the other hand i
do believe in our receivers uh you know
very strongly i do believe in those guys
i do believe
in hollywood brown miles boyk and devon
duvenay james crochet sammy watkins we
do believe in those guys uh we also
believe in bateman we also believe in in
teal and wallace as well and we think
we've really you know strengthened that
class of players and that's going to
make us a better offense
how much sleep did you lose the night
before you sent orlando brown jr to the
team that lamar jackson has called the
ravens kryptonite the kansas city chiefs
you know that's tough you know as you
when you trade a good player uh it's
tough when you trade a good player who's
a great person that's tougher and this
was a decision that we made you know
what we thought was probably best for
the ravens long term
and also probably you know what the
player really wanted and and we try to
be a team that's going to do what's best
for the club but we also want to
accommodate our players if possible
i've known orlando since he was a little
boy
um because of his father's involvement
with this franchise and orlando's a guy
that does everything the right way he's
tough he's physical he's got a high care
factor
um
you know i would have loved and i think
john would have loved to keep orlando
here long term
it was going to be very tough with us
based on the salary cap based on the
fact that we've got other good players
coming up as well
and orlando wants to be a left tackle
that's a lifelong dream of his
and so
you know
it was hard to train them it was
probably harder harder to trade them to
the chiefs an organization that we
respect a very talented organization
um a super bowl super bowl winning
organization that was a challenge but
again as a gm i've got to look at the
short term of the franchise and also the
long term of the franchise and for us to
get what we did given the parameters
we're under it seemed like the smart
thing to do
hey last one for you and i appreciate
you giving me so much time schedule
comes out wednesday night may 12th
what's the first thing you look at when
it pops up on your phone
uh december i look at the december games
because i know those are going to be
critically important and those can
really you know impact your team last
year was a great example
our schedule was very tough at the
beginning of the year and our december
schedule was was was pretty fortuitous
and
we ran the table and that was a great
thing for us to get into the playoffs
you know momentum and all those kind of
things so i think the december games are
very very big we'll look at the home in
a ways in december i'll look at that and
uh and we'll see what it looks like
are you confident there's going to be
full stadiums in baltimore
i you know i hope i'm hopeful you know i
mean i we came out with a statement this
year this week that we we would we would
hope that and expect that um
you know hopefully this country
continues to do what it's doing i think
vaccinations will be a big deal
um
you know
i think all that stuff's important and
uh i i do hope sincerely that we can
have a 100 capacity in our stadiums this
year that'd be a great thing for
baltimore for the city for the community
for our fans and we we really do hope
that to be the case
well well said and i appreciate so much
some of your time congratulations on
another draft congratulations on 25
years with the baltimore ravens here's
to 25 more eric thank you
when did you come out to training camp
that time how many years ago was that
remember that 2006 was that what it was
yes
wow long time ago long time ago long
long time ago hopefully uh hopefully
we'll get back there again sometime soon
i hope for another 25 more for me and i
hope for another 25 more for you and i
look forward to talking to you again
next time
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports